can you compare and contrast what it's
like building a fan base for your music
to what it's like building a fan base
for this movie the music's took a lot
longer um because I once again I taught
myself to play in front of people you
know I started playing very quickly
after I picked up an instrument in front
of people and clubs and booking shows
and things like that and I wasn't very
good for a long time but I was really
emotional and people like to see that
like we're gonna pay to see a meltdown
and I was they wanna see this guy
meltdown so then later eventually became
a joyful experience when I started to
you know figure out the instrument and
songwriting craft and all that and it
went from a depression depression type
of thing to a very fun upbeat good time
you know and with film it is such a
quicker it was quick quicker for me to
get that instant the gratification
because I'm not playing or physically
doing anything with any type of
technical issues is instant
gratification of seeing you know a scene
performed well and as far as van base
goes with that that's just beginning to
happen i had a fan base in New York for
my plays we sold out a lot of 99 seat
theater plays for 26 or 28 performances
every one of them and that was a I'm
proud of that but let's put the movies
it's just beginning now because I really
just finished you know quick the duck
here it's the first film I'm really
proud of and I'm really pushing so the
fan base is uh I think it's going to be
pretty cool because it's different type
of film it's not the same ol same ol
stuff you see I mean you said you
started your music on stage can you tell
me about those early days and I'm just
happy because you know the most people
they start behind the scenes they
practice aying you literally started on
stage tell us yeah I would go on stage
not even knowing what the cords were you
know and I just had such a I was coming
from such an emotional place that I
could bang out a couple chords you know
and the Redman would be all over the
place but i would just had the talent to
be able to put out emotion over the
instrument and i was very emotional was
what I'm saying what was that first
experience though I'm it was this like a
coffee shout out blues club blues club I
started playing blues clubs right off
the bat Kansas City pretty big ones too
you know how did you end up on stage I
walked in the club I said who do I have
what I did get on the stage here this is
we can bring somebody in that's uh no
they said first let me listen to
something why don't have anything I'll
be right back so I went recorded
something and then I came back in I said
they say you can come in on a Sunday or
something doing open mic I said I don't
do that how about what if I bring
someone in here that's uh and that's
known and to bring it they'll bring in
his fan base and I just open up for and
play one or two songs can we do can I do
that and they're like shirt and so then
I would go out and find people and I'd
say hey what's your availability next
month do you have any dates the year in
town because i'd like to see if you want
to do a show at this club and they know
where you book and there now no but i'm
working with the owner you told me if i
could get you to come in and do a show
that i may be open up for you this is
all really cool and so I did that and I
start that's how I started and from
there I got another booking where the
owner liked me he liked what I was doing
and I opened up
for alejandro escovedo who's a the
godfather of Americana he's a legend and
I opened up for him and you know got a
lot of press for it and stuff and my
career started then and it was it was
different every time it was just it was
an emotional experience you know it was
very punk you know very one man an
acoustic guitar you know I'm it's
fascinating that you know what made you
think to do it that way Matthew right
rather than do it sort of the open my
crowd honey I I didn't want to do that
cuz i knew that i could i knew that i
was getting a reaction right off the bat
his people were like jesus oh my god you
know right off the bat because i'm very
intense you know and i was getting a
positive reaction right at the back so
and plus it was bringing me out of a
hard time in my life you know so I don't
want to waste my time so I was in the
papers I was in the wrong radio as far
as being in shows announced and getting
noticed right off the bat now not always
the best did one show be amazing the
next show would not be so amazing people
would say to me what was going on with
you that night it was so based on how i
was feeling emotional so i didn't want
to waste my time with that so years
later I took the time to learn what I
was doing and then I made an album and
things got to go good with that and I
just think it's right that you wanted to
immediately be in front of people and
perform rather than you know take the
risk and may be performed by have no I'm
there to see you well I've done that you
know you'd be the musician nowadays you
have to deal with that wants to go home
um no I just like I said I just saw
right off the bat ways to get get
getting in the press and the clubs would
like me in the press would uh um do nice
rug little nice write-ups you know but
this wild blues singer from Kansas
and I said why look back you know so how
soon before you started performing
outside of Kansas City I was doing the
music in Kansas City from 96 to 2002 and
I moved to New York and New York is
where I continued to do music and got
into film and theater as well and in New
York I just doing music at a club up
there every week and we had such a
popular show that the bartender's from
Saturday night were one to work on our
night because we were packed packed
there's a me and three or four other
songwriters that were just putting on
really good shows and emotional crazy
intense powerful soulful music you know
and not the same as everybody else you
know a lot of people just copying other
people
you